if you have concerns about China shut up
you racist xenophobe far left Democrats
defending the chinese-owned app Tick
Tock as its CEO gets hauled before
Congress and testifies for the first
time lawmakers are looking to ban it
over National Security risks there are
damning reports that the social media
giant has been spying on journalists
scooping up the personal data of 150
million American users and pushing
political propaganda it's a rare
bipartisan effort but a member of the
squad would rather make it about
identity politics
why the Hysteria
and the panic and the targeting of tick
tock Republicans in particular
have been sounding the alarm creating a
Red Scare around China let's not be
racist towards China and express our
xenophobia when it comes to Tick-Tock
Republicans ain't got no swag that's why
they want to bang bang
Republicans ain't got no swag that's the
problem
um Tick Tock CEO trying to convince
Congress that the company is not an
agent of the Chinese Communist party but
that didn't go well
I have seen no evidence that the Chinese
government has access to that data they
have never asked us we have not provided
well you know what I've asked that
because I find that actually
Preposterous if we don't sell data to
any data broken you don't sell to anyone
we don't sell data to data Brokers I
didn't ask your data Brokers has bite to
inspired on American citizens I don't
think that spying is the right way to
describe it do bite dance employees in
Beijing have access to American data we
rely on global interoperability and we
have employees in China so yes the
Chinese Engineers do have access to
global data Tick Tock has repeatedly
chosen the path for more control more
surveillance and more manipulation
your platform should be banned but what
Dems really fear the most is that a
Tick-Tock ban could end the gravy train
of support from younger voters Democrats
from the top on down turned the turn to
the app to reach gen Z remember Beto
putting the lotion on the skin ahead of
the midterms and worse a band would
probably ruin Lori lightfoot's new
career as a karaoke singer so Jesse I
think this is like an important moment
because this is It's like a the
hearing's like a hotel flashlight that
shows you who's on the payroll and who
isn't yeah it looks like the squad
member got taken to dinner by a few
tick-tocks
it's so obvious yes yeah dinner after
dinner after dinner and I'm sure there's
more where that came from it doesn't
matter to me if they ban it or not
because Biden's going to get blamed
Republicans aren't going to get blamed
all the young people that are on it are
just going to blame the White House now
I signed up for a tick tock account
because I thought that was the thing to
do to promote the show and I go on and I
enter in all my demo graphics and then
they ask me personal questions about my
likes and their my dislikes and all of a
sudden I log on and I'm flooded with the
exact same video
30 year old white moms dancing to
hip-hop in kitchens
apparently that's
and I don't like that because we spy on
other people through our platforms
Google Facebook Twitter the Chinese
aren't allowed to do that that's our
territory but the political correctness
thing that's what really bothers me
because let's just say in World War II
Bowman was around what he was going to
give Truman hell for Save Nagasaki you
don't want to bomb Nagasaki because
they're going to call you racist against
Japanese you don't want to let that woke
ideology enter International Security
because then that actually puts lives in
danger well you know what's interesting
uh Dana people are talking about the
spying they're talking about the data
but the thing it's a psyop and we're in
a way that China the the company can
amplify stories and videos that
manipulate the mindsets of the people
who use it and that's what when you're
seeing you know teenage girls with
depression and suicide boys who are no
longer articulating with the opposite
sex preferring instead to look at these
Tick Tock videos isn't that a bigger
problem if you have kids well I thought
one of the most interesting parts of the
hearing was where he had to explain to
everybody why his kids are not allowed
on Tick Tock oh yeah and
there China doesn't allow our apps in
China okay so do we have to allow theirs
in America I don't know but I don't
think the Biden Administration has done
a very good job of articulating the
national security threat one of the best
questions yesterday at the White House
briefing was from Grady Trimble from Fox
Business he asked well if does the
president for Banning Tick Tock are
having it sell itself off but just last
week for St Patrick's Day he made a St
Patrick's Day video on Tick Tock yeah so
is it do as I say not as I do or what
does a what does the president actually
want people to think and then when you
look at what has happened in the last
week or so in the media there's been a
defensive Tick Tock well what happened
let me to give you a couple of numbers
in 2019 Tick Tock spent 270 000 on
lobbying not that much okay
last year 5.3 million
so they know that they have a way to try
to do that so they brought their
influences their influencers there
somehow they got to Jamal Bowman but
that's take that's a lot of money to
spend to allow China who is
undertaking a genocide which you'll hear
more about today when the China
committee has their Prime Time hearing
uh I I do think that it is time for
Americans to take one moment and say wow
bipartisanship is still possible in
America that was a pretty good hearing
today and the members of Congress were
actually pretty prepared on a
technological issue which they're
usually not yeah you know Jessica it's
kind of uh it is it tells you the
seriousness that people take this that
actually left and right can get together
and talk about it but must bother you
that there are people on your side that
always use race as an intimidation
tactic they don't want you just they
don't want to debate so they just call
you a racist I'm tired of it Jessica it
bothers me mostly that you bring it up I
could live with it if it was just out
there in The Ether but that I have to
talk about it every day
um I was glad that he was so far are out
on a limb by himself in this particular
defense and it should add that the
American civil liberties Union is on his
side about it so it's not this is a
couple Squad Members Plus an important
Free Speech organization not anymore
their reputation has definitely been
degraded for sure but it still is
something it's not a nothing
organization
um I thought the hearings were great I
still think the younger members showed
up the older members a bit but it was
nice to see that Republican and
Democratic members both knew what they
were talking about and went for
different angles you know how sometimes
they just like hit the same thing but it
seemed like everybody had a little piece
of the puzzle I don't know if it was
bipartisan coordination which would be
incredible but I was impressed by that
one of the outstanding issues and I
should know so the only social media
that I have is Twitter and I use that to
stay in touch with the news I very
scared of social media generally and I
was talking to a tech journalist who
actually has a separate phone for tick
tock she's aware of the fact that she
needs to be on it but doesn't want it to
be anywhere near her other data doesn't
let her kids on it
um but one issue that I don't think was
well enough addressed by AI that we want
to ban it folks is the 5 million small
businesses that are on Tick Tock and
this is the issue as well with like
Amazon marketplaces you need to make
sure that you're taking care of the
people whose livelihoods are dependent
on this and that isn't the 23 year old
influencers that are you know roasting
tomato and feta on a one sheet and then
pouring it into a something those are
people who won't survive off of this
without it and I realized Tick Tock
wasn't around a few years ago it's the
nature of the business there will be
something new I hope it is an American
Pro why can't we make America yeah
something called Instagram yeah yeah but
dancing you could act you could
absolutely move from Tick Tock to some
of the American social media platforms
but the amazing part of this is that I
didn't hear a lot of discussion today
and and by the way I was thrilled that
it was bipartisan I mean as an American
I looked at them testifying and I said
isn't that great the Democrats and the
Republicans are agreeing on something
but you know the dangers they're
biometric identifiers I mean that they
are exploiting us uh and and this guy
who comes in he was evasive he was
misleading I think he thought someone
said he wasn't prepared no I think he
thinks that we're stupid that bite dance
isn't answerable that the parent company
Tick-Tock isn't answerable to the CCP
that the CCP can't just come in and say
to bite dance you know I want to see
everything that's on there and then when
you kind of join it with what else is
going on you know uh the the China the
CCP just had a spycraft going over our
intercontinental ballistic missile sites
you just have Putin now meeting with Xi
Jinping talking about a new world order
I mean it's it's is it a surprise that
they would use this particular medium to
get information on us to be able to spy
on what our kids do and be able to know
everything about what's going on and
while we're at it we ought to look at
Google we ought to look at our own
social media sites and these people who
respond with it's racist to go to be
against the Chinese it just shows you
how shallow they are they're not
interested in looking into what the
problem is and he doesn't even talk
about the uyghurs or the concentration
camps or you know the genocide as Dana
mentioned that's going on in China I
mean it's just everything is true the
lens of racism well you've got to give
that up you've got to deal with the
facts because racism doesn't mean
anything anymore it doesn't mean
anything to me anymore when someone says
someone else is a racist so I mean I
think this was a good day for America I
think with the continuing hearings on
China people will hopefully start to
recognize how dangerous China is to the
United States you know the downside to
Banning Tick Tock no Libs of tick tock
oh no we and you know what I I'm stop
maybe that's why the Dems want it gone
because the lives of tick tock has done
more to expose wokism on on social media
than almost on Twitter too though so
let's take it over yeah no but I mean
it's only best stuff comes from Tick
Tock the crazy screwed up teachers I
don't follow with more piercings than a
bait and tackle shop I love it I went on
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now